[Applause]
f to the x welcome to the very first
down the middle episode when we're going
to be talking
currencies uh this is not a subject that
we've delved into before on the other
hand
the most amazing currency thinker has
been buried on the sell side for a very
long time
think of cell side and compliance as
being one and one as in shackled as in
you cannot talk to the media
uh i was privileged enough before he
passed away actually to have tobias
lefkivich on my show and and that was
his first time being able to speak out
uh after being on the sell side for for
20 years today we have brent donnelly
he's president of spectra markets
i've known him for quite some time we've
gone fishing together we won't talk
about that
uh but he's a great guy uh he's canadian
which i'm you know
i'm discovering that canadians in
general do so well on wall street and
rather than me
uh give you his resume because he's been
to a lot of places i'm going to let
brent jump in he started in 95 i started
in 96. so we started on wall street
within months of one another but why
don't you a
uh tell us how you started out in the
business
and b
that little moment in between when you
were not on the sell side what did you
do welcome
sure hey hey so we won't talk about
getting drunk in the canoe okay um
so i started in 1995. and i'm from the
generation of um
liars poker the movie wall street all
that stuff and actually one irony of all
that is that and reminiscences of a
stock operator obviously was has always
been big so one irony of all three of
those pieces of amazing art is they're
all cautionary tales right they're all
basically telling you don't go to wall
street because like it's a horrendous
place but reading that stuff at 14 15
years old i was like i'm going there i'm
gonna be rich so um i was a product of
the of that era and so all i wanted to
do was be a trader basically from the
age of 14 or so
so
out of school i went to uh citibank and
there was no sophisticated analyst
programs back in those days it was like
you know hey there's an empty seat go
sit over there for a couple days and see
if you like it and sit over there for a
bit so literally i sat one day at three
different desks one was t-bills one was
structured products and one was fx which
is what usually what in institutional
people call currency trading so in
retail it's usually called forex and in
institutional side people usually say fx
so the fx trading desk or whatever so
t-bills don't move
structured products are like very
cerebral quantity kind of not trading in
my mind so i was like all right how
about currency trading and now it's like
26 years later i'm still doing it i mean
i love it so
things have changed a lot in the
industry
since i started so when i started 95
the spot desk so spot is um just a
normal currency the way you would go to
the airport and change currencies like a
corporation needs 200 million euros and
they have dollars they come to come to a
bank and they say hey exchange these and
that's what a currency trader does
that's called spot
and so in those days there were 30
people on the on the citibank spot desk
trading you know various sizes of each
currency so you'd have like the small
dollar yen trader medium dollar yen
large dollar yen based on transaction
size
now
fast forward to 2021 almost all of that
market making has become automated so
now most spot desks are like three or
four people so that just gives you a
sense of like just hyperspacing through
time how much things have evolved
so in those days every single
transaction
was
going through an individual trader like
me
was recorded um
manually in a computer but manually so
you had to like punch in the thing
usually you kept your position on a
piece of paper
and the whole thing was just trying to
keep your position straight and make
sure you didn't make mistakes it was
very transactional and flow oriented so
i would liken it to
being a blackjack dealer like that's
kind of fun
but intellectually not all that
stimulating so i did that for a couple
of years
and i've always had like a creative side
of my brain so a friend and i had
written a movie script and i was like
super naive so i'm like i'm gonna go
home to canada and produce our movie
so
that was not realistic and like we tried
to raise money and never did however
um that was when the nasdaq bubble was
just starting to heat up and there were
a lot of um
like so people would use the term bucket
shop but it's actually not the right
term these were like there's a lot of
very professional day trading firms that
trained you and they were legit and i
went to one of those so it's like a
trading floor
where it's free to sit down but you have
to pay you pay commission so i started
doing that and then actually i wrote a
cartoon um or i had a concept for a
cartoon which i made a pilot for with a
friend of mine and we sold that to a
studio in montreal so we wrote like 13
episodes of the show it was on tv in
canada
um so that was super fun and i learned
so much about like the inside of like
you know um recruiting the voice actors
and you have a vision in your head of
like what the voice is going to sound
like from this character and then you
know you bring someone in it's totally
different but you're like oh my god
that's genius so there's like some
really cool aspects to that that that i
learned wait wait stop stop brent what
was the cartoon called because we can
find anything on the world wide web and
what was it about
so the it was called daft planet like
crazy planet um and it was essentially
like riffing on
how technology and pop culture and music
are getting more and more crazy over the
years and like excel i like the
acceleration of culture and that kind of
thing but through the eyes of like a 12
year old kid to 12 year old kids
um
so the animation was pretty chintzy like
the the episodes cost a lot of money
still like 250 000 or whatever but
that's cheap for uh to make a cartoon
um
so but in those days that was when south
park was just kicking off so the big
emphasis in the in the like animated
animation industry was story over over
animation quality like obviously south
park animation quality was bad but it
didn't matter so we kind of squeaked
through because of that
um it's on youtube you can see it i mean
there's some there's a lot of like
sophisticated humor like um like one of
the episodes is like about the kids get
addicted to video games so it's all uh
like train spotting and requiem for a
dream
and like those drug movie kind of
references
um
so it was i think it was a decent
product but it looks pretty janky if you
look at it now because it's 20 years old
but anyways so i i was trading the
nasdaq bubble and i had a lot of success
doing that um i had a specific
methodology that just worked really well
and
then what happened was around 2002 so i
did that for about four or five years
around 2002 the nasdaq went to decimals
instead of fractions and so that changed
the microstructure of the stock market a
lot in in ways that unless you're really
doing short-term trading didn't really
matter but if you were really do if
you're doing a lot of short-term trading
it made a huge difference um and then
the tv show got cancelled
and then i was thinking about getting
married i'm like now i'm almost 30 i'm
like an actual almost an adult
so then i got back into
a similar job actually trading fx again
um however by that point the industry
had changed a lot and
so now like i'll just fast forward all
the way through so i worked at a hedge
fund and then i worked at a couple of
different banks including lehman when it
went under
um but in the end my role since about
2004 has been very similar which is i
was a market maker and
part of being a market maker is s um
clients ask you like what do you think a
lot so like what do you think dollar
yen's gonna do today i need to buy a
billion dollars in the next 24 hours you
know what's the best way to do that and
that kind of thing and what i found was
i was telling salespeople the same thing
over and over it seemed really
inefficient so i started writing a note
in just like a quick email
and then client then sales people would
say hey can i send this to a client i'm
like yeah it doesn't look very good let
me just clean it up and then slowly so
you know my note so since around 2004
it's become more sophisticated and
nicely packaged or whatever um but it's
still the same idea it's just basically
like here are my thoughts on the market
and as you know i've i talk a lot more
about equities now bitcoin and stuff
um
and so over time that actually became
more important than my market making um
and also like i said market making has
become more and more automated
so now i've moved to a new job where i'm
actually covering clients which are
hedge funds and and asset managers
advising them on fx trades and
derivatives trades so we um we directly
you know facilitate fx options and fx
trades um and then i they've created a
new company for me called spectra
markets which is me attempting to like
deliver my content to a bigger audience
because
i wrote a couple of books
and
one of the big takeaways from writing
those books was
there's a really huge appetite for
trading and like global macro
information and learning um out there
and it's not very well satisfied
in in certain
lanes which like my specific lane which
is kind of tactical macro there aren't
that many books and and that much really
like high quality material so
i found there's a lot of appetite for
that so now i'm trying to like satisfy
that and
going back to the cartoon thing and all
that it
the thing i love doing is basically
trading and writing so
this gives me a chance to write in an
unconstrained way like you said at the
top of the show about the compliance
stuff
is that when you work at a bank um
i don't think people fully appreciate
unless you work at a bank how intense
the compliance infrastructure is um and
it's there for good reason right i mean
these are commercial banks that
are under a lot of scrutiny many of
which got bailed out um in 2008
so
as an employee of those firms
you're you know you're not going to be
running around say criticizing the fed
or or whatever
anything else that you might want to do
that's a little bit controversial so
now being at spectrum markets
i'm kind of free from like the the
compliance bureaucracy um
and the thing is like i loved working at
the banks over the years so like i'm i'm
not like a huge critic of the banks i
mean i had a great career working at
banks and
tons of my friends still work at banks
and all that
um it was just more specifically for me
personally
i wanted more creative freedom and it's
impossible there's there's a very strict
limit to your creative freedom if you
work at a commercial bank well i mean
your twitter handle is literally a
mirror image of itself i don't even know
how you did that
so
and you're not going to tell me are you
my my kind of like philosophy with my
writing is is that it's supposed to be
serious and professional but not boring
so
my biggest beef with um like bank
research especially because that's what
i was mostly exposed to like your stuff
is not boring you're talking about
historical
events and analogies that are really
cool and stuff like that but a lot of
institutional um and not not all of it
because some of it's really good but a
lot of
institutional
finance product
is
very boring and like math oriented and
dry you can
communicate something interesting and
creative but still be rigorous and
mathematical at the same time so like
that's what i'm kind of trying to do is
like have a little bit of fun so my
upside down or mirror image uh
font is just to reflect that like
hopefully i'm not like
super boring anyways
so um
your views right now on currencies are
kind of squishy um there's not a ton of
conviction which is fine it actually
reflects the world we live in but take
us back to
a year in your career when you like went
into the year and you were super super
adamant and you knew that that one
currency was going to move against
another currency and how did that play
out and what was going on in the
background because
we seem i mean today especially it seems
like markets are teflon
and it's really hard to have to see big
moves but take us back to a time when
that wasn't
the case
sure so i think one thing that's really
challenging in general with i think this
is true with macro all over the place
not just fx
is that many many things happen that
people think makes sense but they don't
happen on the timeline that people
expect so
a good example is so for me my my
trading style is more tactical and less
like i would never have a position for a
year for example but i might have a view
of pretty much a core view that lasts
for most of a year um so a good example
of of that would be 2014
when it was kind of the theory was a
little bit wrong but the theory was that
the fed was getting closer to
normalizing um at the same time as the
boj was still doing like ebonomics and
mega easing
and the ecb looked like they were about
to start going to quantitative easing as
the fed was hiking so there's a lot of
monetary policy divergence
and
generally monetary policy divergence is
like the number one driver of currency
markets it isn't always but that tends
to be the number one driver
so in 2014 it looked like you know you
got to be long dollars because fed's
hiking and everyone else is easing and
like that should be the easiest trade
macro wise in the world however then
from january to june july basically of
2014
the dollar did
almost literally absolutely nothing like
say for example dollar yen might move on
average say between seven and twelve
percent in a year let's just say
it was in a range of about one percent
almost for six months like with a couple
deviations but it was basically like me
doing nothing
and so to maintain your conviction in
the face of that is really difficult
um
and
that's one thing that i've actually
learned
so one of my books is just basically all
the
essentially what i've learned in 25
years of trading and one of the things
that that i think is really important in
trade and this is wait wait brent this i
want to pump your book so somebody can
create this is this the art of currency
the art of currency training alpha
trader so alpha trader is like the
mindset methodology and mathematics of
trading so it's essentially like where
my trade ideas come from how i risk
manage them all that kind of thing
um and one thing that can be very
frustrating for trade people with
trading time horizons
is that things just don't always happen
when you think they should right like
so
that that was a really good trade
because i stuck with it and eventually
the dollar went to the moon and i made a
ton of money but you know say you're
buying one month
calls
in because you think the dollar's gonna
go up
well it was months seven and eight when
the when the dollar finally went up so
if you bought one month
options for six months by the seventh
month you're down so much on those other
six months that that you're dead so like
that's that's what happened to me in o7
actually was
the in that time it was there was kind
of like bubbles and everything right
like the housing bubble obviously but
there was a big bubble in fx in kerry um
so essentially all these funds is very
similar to what long-term capital did in
1998. so these funds would buy the
currencies that had the highest yield
with a ton of leverage and then short
the currencies that had no yield so you
buy like australian dollars in new
zealand and you sell yen against it and
that's like an eight percent yield
pickup and you lever it four times and
you should be making 32
so obviously there's no such thing as
free money
um and it became very clear that it was
kind of getting close to a bubble like
there was i think deutsche launched a
carry uh fx etf at that time which is
often an anecdotal sign of of bubbles
um and there's a bunch of other stuff so
however that year i was trying to be
short almost all year and really it
didn't work except for one month in
august everything collapsed but i had
lost so much money from january to july
that like i barely made it back what i
had lost
um so
it's really important for anyone that's
doing any kind of trading
that you have to understand like the
timing and structuring of trades can be
just as important as
as the direction
so you know if you're super macro as an
investor then really you just need to
get the direction and that's why
you know buy and hold over time tends to
be a good strategy because you don't
have to time anything you just sucks in
the long run have gone up and whether
that's true in the future i guess we can
talk about but
um
whereas if you're trading you know say
one month to three months time horizon
you're trying to not only get the
direction right but also the timing um
and the structure of the trade
so in in terms of fx now i can kind of
give you just like the broad overview of
what's happening
um because the interesting thing is that
so much money has flowed into the us in
the last five years under like you know
one of the acronyms is tina which is
there is no alternative
um all the not just u.s money um but
like retail money obviously has gone
completely ape
um but then also foreigners so like
softbank the swiss national bank uh all
kinds of foreign entities have all been
buying us mostly tech right because of
the way the indexes are weighted
so that has been a massive um
tailwind for the dollar so a big part of
re so going into last year people
thought with the fiscal craziness that
the dollar would probably collapse
because he had so much spending and you
know this and that um the twin deficits
was kind of like the theme but the twin
deficits didn't matter because so many
so much money was coming in to us tech
that the dollar just kept going up so
now that framework of like it's all
about rates isn't really true anymore
it's actually more about equity flows so
as the money's been coming out of the
nasdaq recently um
the the that has actually been putting
downward pressure on the dollar
and and funny enough you saw the same
thing in 1999 2000 like the dollar was
was
much much much higher um then than it is
now
and it was the exact same it was the
same mechanism money was flowing into
tech
and money was coming from all over the
world and the weights of technology were
becoming so large that anyone that
bought the index was essentially just
buying in those days it was the four
horsemen so i think it was
i mean you probably know better than me
cisco
microsoft intel and whatever the other
one was
um so it's it's a similar dynamic and
then what you saw when the bubble
in 99 unwound
was
that that was essentially the high in
the dollar it wasn't quite because the
euro actually launched at that time and
there were some like existential
questions about the the euro in 99 2000
as well but then by around 2001 2002
the dollar basically went down in a
straight line like a lot like 35 40
percent against most currencies so like
for example euro dollar went from one
like 100 to 1.60
um between 2001 and 2007.
um and that was when
actually just speaking of anecdotal
things he had like gisele that the model
was like asking to rewrite all her
contracts in euros
i remember that that was like a sign of
the top um
so i'm a fan of those anecdotal things
although you know you have to be careful
not to cherry pick the ones that fit
your your prior view but
um so yeah that's the interesting
dynamic now is that
there's many similarities across a lot
of different markets um between 99 2000
and now and the the fx market is similar
and if anything you could actually say
like the dollar has gone up in the last
few years but it's been very
it's been very unimpulsive like the
dollar hasn't actually gone up all that
much relative to what you would expect
um
which to me suggests that
there are a lot of dollar negative
forces primarily being
the twin deficits are absolutely
monstrous and getting bigger because
of goods right so in through covid when
people stop buying services and and only
bought goods that's bad for for the u.s
deficits for the current account and
trade deficits so
there's a lot of sort of um
invisible downward pressure on the
dollar but it's been offset by these
tech flows
and so
to me the the sort of like macro
direction for the dollar is much more
likely to be down over time because
you know my belief i don't know if you
want to get into the whole monetary
policy cycles now no i mean i i do and i
i i just want to contextualize what
you're talking about and michael michael
hartnett uh at bank of america does a
pretty good job of really zooming out
and giving the biggest of the big
pictures and you know trillion dollars
flowing into u.s equities took out the
prior two decades of inflows superseded
in in one year's time i mean 2021 was as
extraordinary as as it could possibly be
in terms of equity inflows into the
united states that people are always
like look at the differential between
u.s stock market and the rest of the
world and i'm like well no i mean no
kidding of course look at the flows
i mean they had to rescale all those
charts like the y-axis
exploded on all those charts because the
same with retail so it's coming from
every um every angle
and i agree his stuff is fantastic so
before we move on to my favorite area of
central banks um
when you said giselle getting paid in
euros gee that reminded me that people
have started to be uh you know people
have started to ask to be paid in
bitcoins i'm just going to push that
button brent i'm just going to go there
i mean it's yeah it's it's it's a
similar concept is that you know you
don't want to get paid in something at
the lows but let's be serious here it's
complete nonsense like euros are
convertible to dollars at almost zero
transaction costs bitcoin can be
converted to dollars like if you want to
get paid in bitcoin just get your
dollars and buy bitcoin it's it's just
like a pr stunt but it what it is is
people riding the bandwagon of what's
popular and that's why it's an anecdotal
indicator because if the mayor of new
york is saying i'm going to get paid in
bitcoin you know he's not going to be
doing that at the lows right he's going
to be doing that at the highs but if he
really wanted bitcoin you know what he
does is he opens a coinbase account and
buys some bitcoin he doesn't need to get
paid in bitcoin it's just like a
nonsensical pr strategy that people use
um that might or might not get a few uh
comments on youtube i'm just giving you
fair warning right now
for the record i don't really i don't i
don't have a strong view on him i'm just
talking about when people do that it's a
pr stunt it's not like uh it's not an
actual legitimate macroeconomic
view that they need to get bitcoin
because the dollar's about to collapse
if you think the dollar's about to
collapse just buy bitcoin but you have
written about the last bitcoin cycle
uh recently and maybe you can walk us
through that because you're seeing some
parallels play out yeah sure so i think
one thing that that people tend to
to not be very good at um when they're
specialists in specific asset classes
is understanding the impact of macro so
the global monetary cycles are
absolutely
critical for every single asset class
right whether it goes up or down
so if you're um only looking at like
which l1 is going to be which l2 or
sorry which l1 is going to win
in you know solana or avalanche or or
bitcoin or ethereum you're kind of
missing the bigger picture which was
one of the big use cases for for crypto
was to defend against dollar debasement
and and the end of fiat currencies
um as central banks print like crazy
animals um
and
that part of the cycle is gone so you
can see this is a good this chart is a
good example
of we've just crossed below the zero
line
of global central bank liquidity whether
it's being added or subtracted so
liquidity is now starting to come out of
the system and markets aren't stupid
they'll get ahead of that so that's to
me why crypto has been
in
a cyclical bear market and i've been
writing about this since november so
this isn't hindsight hairy type stuff
when the fed starts withdrawing
liquidity and the world starts taking
liquidity away that's not good for
risky assets and crypto is a risky asset
um it's not a safe haven
so the issue is that you have so the
monetary cycle policy or sorry the
monetary policy cycle
um is bearish for risky assets in
general anything that was buoyed up by
the liquidity burst
now is at risk that that liquidity gets
taken away so you know that applies to
nasdaq or crypto and and other things
and and the last time we saw the the
charts flip was 2017 headed into 2018.
we went from like like 2.1 trillion of
global qe to like oops we're going
negative here right right and i think
the the
relative amount of qe personally it is
my own opinion the relative amount of
balance sheet expansion is more
important for asset prices than rate
hikes so the fact that the fed is moving
quantitative tightening earlier
to me is even more bearish for crypto
and then if you look at i don't know if
you want to go into the weeds on this so
i'll keep this part short but there's
there's also the having cycle which is
basically the speed at which bitcoin are
able to be mined
is divided by two every four years so
that's called the halving cycle and
there's a point in the having cycle
right after it happens that bitcoin has
tended to outperform and then now we're
in the latter part where it tends to
perform very poorly so i will say the
sample size is small because there
haven't been that many four-year cycles
in the life of bitcoin but historically
that's been the way so what you have now
is the having cycle which is more of
like a internal thing idiosyncratic to
to bitcoin and then the macro cycle
which is the fed they're both going the
wrong way if you're long crypto so
that's why i've been bearish since
november and
really i'll either be jet leaning
bearish or neutral
until the next fed easing cycle and then
probably we go like
beyond the moon in crypto because i do
feel like the use case is legit when
central banks are printing money however
the problem you have if you're long
crypto is they're not right so if
they're not printing money
then the dollar debasement trade doesn't
really work and the thing i think is
that
people aren't intellectually honest so
like on the when when quantitative
easing or qe is happening everyone's
like well by definition that means
crypto has to go up and stocks have to
go up but then when qt happens which is
the opposite of qe like literally
mathematically the opposite of qe
there's a different group of people who
generally their prior was bearish who
will say okay that's bearish but the
people that are bullish never actually
take the new information and so like i
think one of my skills is that i'm just
pretty agnostic like i don't have a
permanent view one way or the other i
try to just ride the cycles and you know
that can mean that that sometimes you
don't have a view and that that's maybe
harder to sell if if you're writing all
the time um but for me that's just more
my style i think it's more my
personality is to
to start from like an agnostic point of
view and then look at try to look at
what the information says and right now
the information says liquidity is
decreasing
um and that's not good for speculative
assets so you go you can create a
spectrum of like from least to most
speculative and web 3 is the most and
you know you can go from there um and to
me some parts of web 3 like the game
game fight
part is actually getting was probably a
bubble at one point so you have some
really really speculative assets that
are going to have a lot of difficulty
maintaining value in a world where the
fed is about to between
you know sometime between april and july
quantitative tightening is going to
start which means the fed's balance
sheets going to get smaller
and i believe that's bad for risky
assets
um can you explain because i think that
i i think jay powell is going to do his
level best to not use the term
quantitative tightening so can you
explain as if i'm a fifth grader
what the treasury maturity schedule is
and compare that to the makeup of the
fed's balance sheet and the fact that
jay powell doesn't actually have to say
quantitative tightening he can just
allow organic roll-off and in 2022 and
20-23 that's a big deal right right so
last time when they reduced the balance
sheet they never really sold i mean
there was some tiny sales of of
high-yield or whatever but generally
they didn't really sell assets what
happens is the assets start expiring and
they put a cap on how much they'll allow
to expire and the balance sheet gets
smaller in that way and we're talking
about small numbers like in 2018
the balance sheet um you know the
monthly contraction the balance sheet
might be between like a half a percent
and one percent
um and when they're increasing the
balance sheet as you know you know they
increased it 20 in in less than a year
at one point or whatever so
it's it's very always that's that's part
of the problem of the current form of
capitalism is that
the accommodation is extremely
aggressive and the withdrawal is very
uh slow and often by the time the
withdrawal's happening
the timing's horrendous because you like
now you've already got fiscal drag and
many other things that could be weighing
on the economy but the fed takes a very
long time to withdraw
and so what will happen when when it
starts is essentially like you said they
just sit there and do nothing but the
the path
or the default path of the balance sheet
is that
because of the maturation of the
securities that are on the balance sheet
it will very slowly get smaller and like
you're saying it is a massive number but
relative to the size of the balance
sheet it's pretty small but but
continually month after month it adds up
pretty fast
so
i mean
this is a really big topic in terms of
what the fed will do and what they
should do and there's a lot of different
uh viewpoints on it like to me it makes
a lot more sense for them to focus on on
quantitative tightening at first it
keeps the yield yield curve steeper and
um it's generally kind of like makes
more sense considering the size of the
balance sheet
but
there's a group within the fed that
thinks that so for example the kansas
city fed wrote a thing saying they
should actually contract the balance
sheet before they hike which if i was
doing it that's what i would do but
obviously i'm not um but then there's
also
2018
which is the last time they did this is
not that long ago and people remember
you know there were some really big down
moves in equities
and so the question is
what's the priority now i don't think
that the fed's priority is equities
anymore so i think that's a pretty
important dynamic that's changed um the
politics
were always for almost my whole life
were were more always about jobs and and
for since 2008 about equities and jobs
and now the politics are really about
inflation right like that's what people
actually care about is inflation not not
jobs because everyone has a job and not
equities because like they've gone up so
much and also there's a pretty strong
i don't know if i'd say understanding
because that like
makes it sound like it's a truth with
but there's a strong belief
that
the qe impact on equities has
contributed a lot to to the perception
or reality of wealth inequality
because obviously rich people own stocks
so if you send the nasdaq from 4 000 to
16 000
which happened since 2016
that's going to benefit rich people a
lot more than people work that are
living paycheck to paycheck so the
politics on that have changed as well
so
my my view is kind of that that they're
not really going to care as much about
that and then the other thing that's
kind of overlaid on all of this is that
there's always been this thing called
the fed put which i know you know about
but i'm just in case anyone doesn't know
exactly what that is which is the belief
in the market that if stocks drop 20 or
more the fed will cut or or ease
monetary policy
and that's easy to do when inflation's
two percent right because the in secular
stagnation you just go well whether it's
at 2.3 or 1.8 it honestly is is a joke
right it's a rounding error but when
inflation's at seven percent and stocks
dropped 20 percent
to me it's not as obvious that they can
cut because like
cutting rates
when or doing more qe when inflation's
at seven percent
could potentially
be like a a really really major
turning point for this whole debt trap
dynamic right
well i mean and plus it's an election
year
and as an fx trader
you know these are all things that you
have to take into account in fact i i
would ask you the question
uh
in an environment like this in a
backdrop like this when things are as
sensitive as they are right now when
it's very easy for the fed to break
something
um do geopolitics matter more
against this backdrop
well i think in general it's been mostly
that so it geopolitics are are strange
things so the way i would put it is that
you you could say like most earthquakes
aren't very serious
but obviously some of them destroy
cities right so that's like
an important it's like a power law thing
so geopolitics is kind of like that like
where most geopolitical um situations
could be have important ramifications
for the people involved and you know
the residents of those countries but for
markets generally most of the time it's
a shrug and we move on right um however
there are occasional times where
geopolitics can be absolutely massive
like
of course 911 is the biggest possible
one you can imagine um but there are
others as well so the the russia ukraine
thing is is definitely interesting
um but it's you know
i don't have a view on whether it
happens but i would say
a russian move into
into ukraine is bigger than normal or
bigger than say crimea because
there's a cohort
of people in the world that believe that
that china and taiwan could actually
there could be enough of a distraction
from russia that china maybe thinks
about doing something as well
again i'm not a geopolitical expert but
what i am aware of is what the
narratives are and i know that's a
narrative that people will embrace is
that you know this could be a domino in
the
sort of like the
the ongoing very slow motion decline of
the us as the ultimate like single
monolithic power in the world
um that you know russia going into
ukraine could be a little catalyst to an
accelerated portion of that so
uh people are definitely watching that
very closely
um
but
to me what it what it is is like it's a
big deal if it happens but i don't have
a there's experts that could have a
better handle on the probability of it
happening than than i could
well but on a practical level if you
want to go back to currencies you know
xi jinping wants an unprecedented third
term
sometime around november my my favorite
uh my favorite little factoid is that
for people born in the year of the snake
which xi jinping was the month of
october is very unlucky so it's kind of
like jack it's like jackson hole they
don't announce the actual dates and
who's going to be speaking until like
the very last minute so i'm voting for
november for the for for the 20th
people's congress but
at the same time when you bring up the
idea of taiwan i immediately think to
how how strong the yuan is right now and
that's problematic for somebody who
wants to make sure that there's no
social unrest in the year that he wants
to be re-elected well you know what's
interesting about that i hadn't thought
of this until you just said it
is that um do you remember what happened
after the last time there was an
olympics in china
what was this um the devaluation
well it was august 2008 so basically
everything kind of held together and
then the world ended so there there's
always this argument that
china obviously has a lot of this this
isn't an argument this is probably a
fact but they have a lot of control over
their economy and market prices but no
one has ultimate control over market
prices in the end you saw that with many
you know the bank of england in 1992
um you saw it with the swiss national
bank in 2015
you know
government forces trying to hold markets
for prolonged period
can work for a very long time a longer
than speculators most speculators can
stay solvent but not forever right
so
if there is something like that going on
then you would think after they're
they're holding everything together the
the real estate deleveraging and all
that they're probably trying to hold it
together until the till the olympics and
the congress are over
and then you kind of go all right we did
the best we can and then you just let
everything go um
on the currency side that's been a real
real head scratcher for a lot of people
i mean a lot of money has been lost
trying to to go against that move
and the thing is it again they they use
the currency as a policy tool so
when inflation was rising um so now
inflation doesn't look like as much of a
threat there
as it does over here but when it did
look like a threat ppi was through ten
percent pork prices were going nuts and
all that it kind of makes sense to keep
your currency stronger um and then you
can buy foreign goods more more easily
and keep inflation tame um and then at
the same time
the speculators are always trying to go
we're trying to go the other way so that
creates like you know
a bit of pressure to
when people have to cover their shorts
and by buy you on again um so there's
been like that speculative thing which
has been hurting people
and then there's also been a pretty
amazing carry trade which is more like
on the institutional side
um where if you bought chinese bonds
they're one of the few bonds where you
could actually earn like a pretty decent
interest rate
so
there's a whole bunch of like inside
baseball stuff with that like the the
wigby which is a big index um they got
added to that china got added to that so
there's been a lot of just like passive
money flowing into into chinese fixed
income chinese bonds specifically
and now that they're starting to cut
rates
um there's probably an interesting
opportunity to to go the other way
you just have to do it in a way that you
don't have to time it perfectly because
kind of going back to our original
conversation
this thing's like impossible to time um
but they've shown that they can lose
control of it so in 2015
um they tried to do this kind of
controlled devaluation of the yuan
and i mean that everything went
absolutely pear-shaped like it was a
goat rodeo that dollar china exploded
they lost control of it for a while they
were intervening like crazy and actually
it triggered a domino story as well like
um commodities collapsed because of it
and
um so capital flight i mean it was
everything yeah
yeah so it's it's a really good
indicator to watch um because
essentially it's a policy lever so you
can look at it as
a policy tool that they have that they
control like 95 of the time and then
once in a while they lose control to the
speculators um or to them to market
forces
um
so yeah that's kind of my view on it is
that like it's gr it keeps on grinding
stronger and stronger
but it makes less and less sense as time
goes on so it's it's definitely
something to watch for
um because there's a lot of sort of
very slow motion grinding but very
negative things happening there
especially on the on the housing
deleveraging side where you know
they i'm sure you've seen the charts of
like home ownership in china
is is so so so high i mean many people
own two homes and all that so
that's going to be like a multi-year
deleveraging story um but it hasn't come
through the currency at all
no it hasn't and you know our our our
mutual friend leland miller has some
really
extraordinary views on
on
on how uncomfortable
xi jinping is with the whole idea of
this fed tightening cycle that he is
just he's just wiggling in his shorts
right now because it's something that is
not in his control what the fed does yet
what the fed does affects the currency
that's an aspect that that china doesn't
control and the other thing that that
leland has uh commented on is the copper
market and the fact that there's a
copper market in shanghai and the
chinese authorities are not kind of
accustomed to speculators being able to
to take the reins occasionally and yet
we've seen that in copper
i mean that's the interesting thing
about if you're going to try to build
like a
socialist
um dictatorship or i guess whatever you
want to call it with capitalist
qualities sort of brewing underneath
man that's like a quite the needle to
thread in the long run and like i said
we've seen many examples of policy
makers holding stuff wherever they want
but
in that's you know ultimately
market forces are are very strong and
and even stronger than than government
forces generally so we'll see how it
plays out but
so um so we have a new and different
macro brand so it's like wow
i mean you're like way out there so what
are
what what are some of the things that
you're that you're following
i mean
on the macro side what is what are some
of your go-to's and um and and go global
and and then come domestic
sure so i mean my main kind of global
macro view now is
that so one source of edge that i have
is i just talked to a lot of people like
i have a lot of clients and a lot of
connections from oh so just from being
around for a long time
and working at different places and i
worked at a hedge fund i worked at banks
i worked at investment banks so
i get a good sense i think of like what
the vibe is and people are just way too
complacent on risky assets in my opinion
so we have just gone through like
literally the greatest monetary policy
experiment in history right like
every single central bank
blew up their balance sheet um and
fiscal spending went absolutely nuts to
so ben hunt has written about this um
like the snip between
spending and taxation there's so many
snips right between things that used to
be linked like taxation and revenue that
have just completely decoupled and so
that led to a completely different
mentality on fiscal um and on monetary
policy and both of those things are
reversing so
you have now you know for example the
child tax credit just ended that's a lot
of money out of people's pockets that
was getting spent
um and then you have obviously the turn
and the fed and if you look at where
we've come like if you look at where the
f where fed expectations were like let's
say in june of last year versus where
they are now
if someone had forecasts
that the fed was going to hike in march
probably nqe in march and maybe be doing
quantitative tightening in july of 2022
like people would have said dude you're
an idiot there's no zero chance that's
gonna happen so like the pace of this
pivot
is really really fast and i think that's
underappreciated and what you see is a
lot of people saying ah you know like
usually three rate hikes before stocks
start going down people are using the
analogy of of the last four cycles which
were generally like secular stagnation
slow motion
yeah and they lasted like a decade i
mean this is the last cycle
qe3 ended in 2012 they hiked in
basically 2016 but late 2015 and qt was
2018 that's like six years of runway now
we're talking about like the biggest
expansion of monetary of central bank
balance sheets in history and now we're
going to do a contraction like 12 months
not even really it's from the time they
stop buying to the time they start sell
or start running off it could actually
be like a four month window and last
time we're talking about six years so i
feel like saying like any analogy that
people use that oh fed rate hikes aren't
bad for risky assets absolutely that was
true in the past
but this isn't is not to me anyways is
not analogous at all
so we can put up this chart of or this
table that shows the starting position
of the economy
each time that the fed started
tightening
so if you look at where
say let's say where core cpi or core pce
works those are the what the fed looks
like looks at for inflation
um the last three cycles
2004
uh core pc was 1.7
2013 it was 1.6
now we're talking about seven percent
like on on cpi that not pce but seven
percent on cpi
um if you look at like something like
jolts which i think is a good indicator
um
it's around 10 million now and it was
like 4 million the other cycles
uh if you look at you can see this on on
the table but
almost everything is just completely
different now that this economy is you
can argue this is like an overheating
like
definitely not hyperinflationary but
extremely inflationary reflationary
economy like something that i haven't
seen in my lifetime i mean never in my
lifetime were restaurants closing for
three days because there's not enough
people to work at them right and that's
all that kind of stuff is happening so i
i think
like in global macro it's very
first of all logical but also very
popular to find analogs so you say like
oh yeah this feels like the cycle this
feels like what happened in 2012 or this
feels like what and then you can kind of
benchmark and the famous one was that's
how paul tudor jones predicted the crash
of 1987 was you know there was other
charts that looked like that and and
predicted so he predicted that way so
it's a useful way of predicting things
that's kind of what like it's pattern
recognition it's kind of what a lot of
people do
um but i think it's wrong right now
because there is not a good analog to to
this this is like
crazy town
you know historic stuff that's happened
in the last 18 months
and you can really see that if you put
if you look at any graph of economic
data
like what i've been doing in my writing
is essentially like if i want to show a
graph of like okay here's what retail
sales looked like over the last 10 years
i just clipped 20 20 out of there
because the you know it blows up the
y-axis it's it's completely insane so
to
any analogy that's looking at recent
cycles
just doesn't make any sense to me and i
think people are getting well to sleep
by this idea that oh it'll be
everything's going to be all right and
i'm just i just don't believe it partly
because it's happening so fast
um partly because of the starting point
which means that
you know in 2018
they they were hiking and and powell
said we're a long way from neutral and
then they were cutting a year like in in
whatever june 2019 and they were already
signaling they were going to cut by
january 2019 because stocks collapsed on
christmas eve 2018.
if stocks drop 20 right now
they're not cutting rates you know
they're not re-embarking on a qe program
so to me the fed put is not around
and i just don't think any of that's
been fully appreciated so in equities or
in crypto where
like it should people and equity should
appreciate it um because that's you know
we've been through so many cycles in
crypto i think people are just too
focused on
the idiosyncratic you know what tokens
gonna be
what token is going to be what token or
or you know bitcoin dominance over
ethereum and they're missing out on the
on the whole like global macro which is
you know money
debasement fiat debasement has run its
course for this cycle and now
it's about to be rebased
fiat's about to make a bit of a comeback
yeah no i mean when people ask me
because it's really difficult because
people want to go back to 1999 people
want to go back to 2007.
they want a benchmark
they want but but but they want a modern
benchmark and i'm like uh try 1933 1934
how about that how does that work for
and they're like what and i'm like
i'm like these are big dollar figures
that we're talking about here and and
and
you know i'll never forget you know how
quickly
stocks declined when the pandemic hit
and you had to go back to 1933 to find a
parallel and i'm like whoa something big
is going on here and then they came
flying right back and i went whoa
something even bigger is going on here
and i think that i think people are i i
agree with you people are missing the
forest for the trees
and um
but but that takes us to a whole
separate
subject
because
whether you're talking about new zealand
or australia or the netherlands or your
home country
if something breaks in the global
economy
there are housing bubbles that make
subprime in 07 looked like a walk in the
park
i don't know where you find this stuff
you put something up on like some house
in toronto
and maybe you can refresh my memory of
what the flip time was
yeah sure maybe you can just share that
with us so we can put it up on the
screen and i was like what did he just
did he is that a typo
yeah i mean we can put it up on the
screen right now so you can see someone
bought a home for a million dollars and
flipped it for 1.7
in 14 months
and with no renaults and that's not like
you know i'm always cautious about these
cherry-picked anecdotes of like the one
crazy thing that happened this is not
like that there's hundreds of these
um
so
i'm not actually as pessimistic on
housing as i am um on other things on
other asset classes simply because
i think part of this is monetary which
like i said i think the tide is coming
back out in the monetary world but then
part of it is is supply so
to me this is like a generational
transfer of wealth from commercial to
residential real estate because of work
from home
so i think people want to invest a
larger percentage of their income
or of their net worth in real estate
versus what they want to do before the
pandemic and i think that's like a
one-time
level shift that that won't come back
so that doesn't mean that prices have to
keep going up but um like what you saw
in 2018 i think um
makes kind of similar it could be kind
of similar where in 2018 when liquidity
started coming out housing prices
stopped going up but they didn't really
come off
um and each country has its own
idiosyncratic stories like in canada
there's not very much supply like
there's a lot of immigration in canada
400 000 you know people last year 400
000 this year which is decent in a
country of 36 million people
um and then you know if you look at we
can put this chart up private dwellings
to population
in canada is very low for a whole bunch
of reasons
so
um i'm not as bearish on housing
although i do see like it's gone crazy
and
one part that that's really um
to me it's almost more like an ethical
thing than than a financial thing but
the amount of investment buying of homes
in a time when you know individuals
can't
buy homes is kind of i don't know it
doesn't feel very it doesn't feel right
to me but whatever free markets i guess
um you know like investment consortium's
putting money together to like buy
entire street blocks and all that um but
i mean there's no law against it they're
not doing anything wrong by the book by
the rules but um that is also
contributing to to the demand side and
that will dry up as financial conditions
tighten so
to me
housing is
like crazy but i don't think it's as
vulnerable just because
it's kind of like the market is short
right like like there's like a natural
short position where a lot of people
want to buy homes and
don't have them and what happens
generally over time is
you get stopped into buying it over time
so like okay say i'm 28 and i live with
my parents
then i'm 30 then i meet someone i get
married finally wherever housing prices
are if i can afford it i end up just
saying okay screw it i'm gonna buy a
house um so i think that eventually that
demand is just latent sitting there of
people that just can't afford to do it
and eventually will just kind of be
forced into it
um
so i think there's not just a demand so
like in a bubble
it's all about demand and usually it's
leveraged and like so people are
borrowing money to buy and then when
prices start going down everyone has to
sell to repay the loans
in this case much more of like around me
a lot of the buying is like 50 cash 100
cash
um
and then in canada a lot of it is
related to not being enough there aren't
enough single-family homes um for all
the the new immigration
so
you know each country has its own thing
but the funny thing is if you look at
all the countries like if you look at a
bar chart of all the countries they're
basically all up 20 roughly so that
argues it's more monetary than than
idiosyncratic right like it's if if
every single country is up 20
then it's kind of stupid to be talking
about
like canadian supply issues you know
because obviously if every country is up
20
the primary driver is probably monetary
and then you have all these secondary
drivers everywhere so i think there's
basically always going to be a bid for
housing um and there won't be as much
panic selling whereas i feel like
0.50607 i mean i worked at lehman so i
know as well as anyone because they were
buying like billions of dollars of las
vegas real estate and then they had to
sell it
is that you know the real trigger for an
unwind of a bubble is the force selling
that's caused by people that borrowed
and levered and you know
but bought a hundred dollars worth of
real estate with ten dollars down
um and then when prices drop 20 percent
you're underwater i don't think that's
as much of a thing in housing
however um i mean
it's you look at these things like that
graphic that we showed before and it's
hard not to to be a little bit worried
a little i'm gonna have to agree with
you there brent just a little just just
do it just a smidge i mean yeah i need
like investors are pushing a third of
the market here in the united states and
they're using leverage it's just
leverage we can't really see
which is a you know we could go off on
that tangent for like a day and talk
about it maybe in a canoe with some wine
you know yes
in any event um i'm gonna wrap this up
and ask you one question
how did you come up with your with your
mantra
good luck be nimble
i mean i've been looking at it for years
and i'm like where did he come up with
that so when i was younger um when i
first started doing client things so you
would go to like you know in those days
and they're still actually mostly the
same names but there was like five to
eight
big names in hedge fund trading that
were like the famous people that you
kind of looked up to that were like the
you know the heroes or whatever so i
wouldn't interact with them but i would
interact with like people that worked
for them so i would always ask them like
hey what do you like why is this guy
such a legend and what makes him such an
incredible traitor
and
unanimously or not unanimously but
almost unanimously was they would say oh
well he'll come into the morning meeting
and say like i'm bullish euro for six
reasons
and then at four o'clock euros down you
know 80 points and you look in his book
and he made money and he's like well
yeah you know things changed i got short
so
it's like that ability
there's this thing there's a cliche or
like a saying which is um strong views
weekly held
which is like do a lot of research and
believe in in your own opinion but then
be open to new information and be ready
to change your view
and i think as an investor that's not as
important because
you have more staying power and you
don't use leverage generally but as a
trader you really have to be
flexible enough to to react to to
changes in the in and react to new
information pretty quickly now obviously
that can mean that you just get blown
all over the place by every crosswind
and you're mr flip-flop and that's not
good
um so it's always finding that balance
but for me
the worst times that i've traded was
when i just had this view and and i just
couldn't let go of it and obviously if
it was right it wouldn't matter but if
it was wrong you know you're it's the
old like if you loved it at 10 you're
gonna love it at five and you're gonna
want to buy even more at two dollars and
fifty cents right um
so being nimble i think is like really
like the smart person's way of thinking
about it would be like being bayesian so
you have a prior view and you have all
the information but a good bayesian then
adjusts as new information comes in
takes their prior you know whatever your
probability expectation of something
happening was x then as new information
comes in
don't just filter out that information
because it doesn't agree with you try to
be open to new information and flexible
and then adapt right and well i mean you
you recently did this and i kind of made
it really famous on twitter all right at
least
i i put a little bit of a flashlight on
it but within 24 hours you had changed
your viewpoint on gold
right
so that's it that's a difficult thing to
do um and actually that's a skill that
i've i've developed simply by
recognizing that i i need to do it and
then once you start doing it a bunch of
times you don't feel as bad
um
but also i'm fortunate because my
switching costs are pretty low like
people kind of know me and generally
know like sometimes i change my mind and
i'm transparent and i'm honest about it
and
it's a bit embarrassing but whatever
life goes on um but if you're like a
strategist at a major investment bank
you can't be saying i'm bullish one day
and then say you know what actually some
new information came in embarrassed now
it's just much more difficult for a lot
of strategists to switch
um whereas as a trader your switching
cost is just like whatever the banner is
right like you should be able to switch
if the new information comes in
um so i kind of like got over it over
time because it is embarrassing to say
like one day i'm embarrassed and
especially when i'm writing about it and
all that and then two days later say
well you know what actually i'm not
bearish um but i think it's a strength
not a weakness
um and i think generally people view it
like that if you explain
why you know not just like oh i have a
weird gut feeling
if you say okay i've analyzed all this
new information and you know now my view
is different i think people respect that
even though as a person doing it it kind
of feels a little bit uncomfortable
well but look
but you're absolutely right and if
there's one thing that i've heard
uh you've heard the nimble and and you
obviously play it out in in real life
and and i've always heard that you have
to have a really strong cell discipline
and it's kind of along the same lines as
that uh brent i have i've learned so
much in the space of however long we've
been talking an hour
and um and i really appreciate the new
you the
non-non-shackled by compliance brent
macro brent twitter brent uh it's just
awesome so i i want to come back i want
to do this in a year let's do this in
person in new york yes sure let's do
this um and thank you so much for
spending so much time i really
appreciate it okay thank you it's fun i
love love hanging out with you
[Music]